c'était vraiment extrêmement difficile
oui heureusement que j'avais quelqu'un
ici sinon je ne devais même pas voir
l'hôtel pas s'appeller de l'afrique
c'est tellement compliqué après 12 jours
au cameroun
lovely n'a condamné à passer des heures
à tenter de réserver sa quarantaine
obligatoire à l'hôtel sabri trois jours
et les deux premiers jo deux heures
d'attenté au téléphone
le troisième jour près du prêt de 2 a
également la tombe sur les atteintes et
long oui ça promet trois heures plus une
attente qui a aussi vécu divine kaoutari
comme tous les voyageurs arrivés par
voie aérienne
elle doit elle aussi se plier aux
nouvelles règles
première étape un test de dépistage à
l'aéroport il fait un peu vite est et on
vous dit que d'apprendre 24 à 72 heures
et puis l'art pouvait aller dans l'hôtel
on nous donnons comme un kit pour vous
faire un test après les 14 euros après
le dépistage
elle prend une lavette direction l'hôtel
pour trois jours un service qui est
inclus dans le forfait de l'hôtel bémont
le moins coûteux des cinq hôtels
montréalais désigné par le fédéral
environ 300 dollars la nuit
repas à la chambre inclus surveillance
caméra et agents de sécurité aussi c'est
pour ce très fins et comme une journée
que c'est normal quand ces terres
occupées à un moment ici une soixantaine
de chambres sont disponibles pour les
quarantaines obligatoire mais l'hôtel
pourrait augmenter sa capacité selon les
besoins ce qui continue de causer
beaucoup de frustration ce sont les
délais d'attentes pour réserver un
numéro de téléphone unique géré par
ottawa à réservation je peux pas là
quand ces décès par an beau sam en
général donc offert à l'association des
hôteliers du québec a proposé au
gouvernement fédéral de permettre aux
hôtels désignés de prendre les
réservations directement une proposition
qui est toujours à l'étude
issigeac audry charbonneau radio canada
montréal